the most important lesson I learned as a
young leader was I don't have to know
all the answers and I don't have to
pretend that I do and the biggest
biggest skill that I learned that
profoundly changed the course of my
career is I learned to ask for help and
it is amazing that when you learn to ask
for help with confidence not I can't do
this and can you help me but I'm like
hey I have no clue what I'm doing can
somebody please help me what I'm doing
here do you know how to do this cuz I'm
an idiot you know if you can learn to
ask for help with conf
it will have more impact on your growth
as a leader and your growth in your
career than almost anything else being
the smartest in the room is not
important being the one who's willing to
ask for help is the most important